[Music]
foreign
and I'm a Solutions engineer at posit I
help customers install and use posits
pro products and help them solve complex
architectural and infrastructure
problems I'm really excited to be
teaching the first ever two-day devops
for data scientists workshop at
positconf this September in Chicago
devops is a process by which the work of
data scientists and developers whether
it's an R markdown report a shiny app or
a model that serves predictions can be
shared and run across devices across
organizations or even across countries
devops ensures that wherever your data
products are they are reliable
reproducible performant and secure I
want to share with you my three top
reasons why you should join us at the
devops workshop
Workshop first you will learn the
fundamentals of devops from the very
beginning if you don't know much about
system administration or infrastructure
as code it's totally fine this course
will be made for you
second reason why you should join is
that we will be learning about devops
from the lens of data science you will
learn how to move your code data science
practices closer to the devops ideal
using continuous integration and
continuous deployment how to write our
code specifically for creating data
intensive applications and how to use
logs to monitor your app
the third reason why you should join the
workshop is that you will leave with
code deployed to the cloud we will be
running our studio server in a Docker
container and even be writing our own
Docker files I'm so excited to see
everyone in September and hope to see
you at the devops for data scientists
Workshop thanks
[Music]